Olá você já parou para pensar que aquele
ma estar ou sintoma estranho que você
vem sentindo pode ser devido à falta de
vitaminas e minerais importantes em seu
organismo Pois é pessoal a falta ou até
mesmo excesso desses pequenos heróis
podem estar por trás de muitos sintomas
e problemas de saúde Então fique comigo
até o final é fundamental esclarecer que
muitos desses sinais e sintomas que eu
vou falar também podem estar presentes
em outras doenças então eles não são
exclusivos da falta de nutrientes eu
quero que vocês fiquem atentos a esses
sinais se você já investigou outras
causas e ficou sem respostas Talvez seja
hora de considerar a possibilidade de
uma deficiência ou até excesso de
nutrientes importantes sinal número um
cra nas pernas pés ou panturrilhas a
falta de alguns minerais e vitaminas
também pode ser o motivo por trás dessas
Dores incômodas e os principais culpados
são magnésio potássio e vitamina B1
também chamado como tiamina se
aparecerem câimbras com frequência pode
ser um sinal de que você precisa
reavaliar a ingestão desses nutrientes
sinal número dois Desejo comer algo
estranho você já teve vontade de comer
coisas bem inusitadas como tijolo ou
argila ou até talvez misturar sabores
que normalmente não combinam como frutas
e sal essa condição pode acometer ter
principalmente mulheres grávidas e pode
estar relacionada com a falta de
nutrientes principalmente o ferro e o
folato também conhecido como ácido
fólico e vitamina B9 mas lembre-se é
sempre importante conversar com o seu
médico o nutricionista sobre a
possibilidade da suplementação desses
nutrientes sinal número três descamação
na pele se isso está acontecendo com
você pode ser um alerta do seu corpo
para necess de ajustes na sua dieta
nesse caso a sugestão é aumentar a
ingestão de ácidos grassos do tipo
omega3 que são super importantes pra
saúde da pele continuando Nossa lista
Vamos para o item sinal número qu pele
oleosa muitas vezes essa condição pode
ser causada por um excesso de produção
de hormônio masculino ou pela falta do
mineral zinco para combater a oleosidade
a dica é adicionar mais AL ricos em
zinco a sua dieta E como sempre Evite o
consumo excessivo de açúcar e agora
vamos para o sinal número cinco ardência
na língua a síndrome de queimação da
boca uma sensação desconfortável de
ardor na boca ou na língua pode estar
relacionada à deficiência de certos
nutrientes Especialmente na vitamina D
de dado que na verdade é um hormônio
também do mineral ferro e as vitaminas
B1 que é tiamina B6 que é piridoxina e
B12 conhecido como metilcobalamina ou
cianocobalamina sinal número seis
rachaduras nos cantos da boca ou no
Calcanhar se isso tem sido um incômodo
para você pode ser que seu corpo esteja
precisando de mais vitaminas do complexo
B especialmente a riboflavina que é a B2
e a niacina que é a B3 Vamos então ao
sinal número sete que é o sangramento ou
gengiva vermelha isso pode ser um sinal
de que o seu corpo precisa de mais
vitamina C um nutriente super importante
pra saúde das nossas gengivas Então
vamos ao sinal número oito visão ruim
especialmente à noite sabe aquela
situação chata quando você está
dirigindo e percebe que não enxerga tão
bem quando está mais escuro isso pode
ser um sinal de que você precisa de mais
vitamina A e como aumentar a ingestão
então da vitamina A fígado de boi ovos
são excelentes Fontes dessa vitamina
super importante para saúde dos olhos
sinal número nove edema o chamado
inchaço nos pés isso pode acontecer
quando a razão contra a proporção entre
o sódio e o potássio no corpo não está
equilibrada para resolver esse problema
é interessante aumentar a ingestão de
verduras e de alimentos ricos em
potássio porque é muito mais fácil estar
deficiente potássio o sinal número 10
lábios rachados se você tem sofrido com
isso pode ser apenas a falta de
hidratação correta
mas também pode ser que seu corpo está
precisando de um up nos nutrientes
especialmente as vitaminas do complexo B
como é o caso da riboflavina B2 sinal
número 11 manchas ou pontos brancos nas
unhas se você já reparou que tem manchas
ou pontos brancos nas unhas isso pode
ser um alerta do seu corpo para uma
deficiência de zinco sinal número 12
perda das Sobrancelhas nas partes
externas se você começou notar falhas ou
perda da parte externa de suas
sobrancelhas isso pode estar ligado a um
nutriente específico que é o iodo que é
o mineral essencial paraa produção de
hormônios da tireoide bem pessoal
chegamos ao sinal número 13 vontade
comer gelo Pode parecer estranho mas
isso acontece e pode ser um sintoma de
anemia então se você tem notado que está
com vontade de comer de mastigar gelo
isso pode ser um sinal de que seu corpo
precisa de mais ferro sinal número 14
angina ou dor no peito é um tipo
específico de dor no peito que surge por
causa de problemas cardíacos pode
indicar que você precise de mais
vitamina e na sua dieta é importante
lembrar que se você tem angina além do
tratamento com seu médico ou médica
aumentar o consumo de vitamina E pode
ser uma boa estratégia irritabilidade e
pensamentos negativos se você sente
frequentemente irritado ou irritada está
constantemente dominado ou dominada por
pensamentos negativos Pode ser que seu
corpo esteja precisando de mais
vitaminas do tipo B1 tiamina e B12
cianocobalamina ou metilcobalamina agora
vamos para o sinal número 16 sintomas de
asma a asma é uma condição que causa
inflamação nos pulmões e pode ser
bastante desafiadora para ser tratada
Acredite algo simples como tomar só pode
ajudar muito especialmente para as
crianças
isso acontece porque a exposição ao sol
ajuda a aumentar os níveis de vitamina D
que na verdade um hormônio e é um
hormônio essencial níveis baixos de
vitamina D podem afetar negativamente a
asma então manter esses níveis de forma
adequada os níveis adequados dessa
vitamina que na verdade é hormônio é uma
estratégia importante para quem sofre
com essa condição sinal número 17
formação recorrente ou seja fica
voltando de hematomas essas marcas que
aparecem na pele indicam o rompimento
dos vasos sanguíneos localizados logo
abaixo do superfície da pele essa
situação é especialmente comum em
pessoas mais idosas tem mais fragilidade
capilar também chamado de fragilidade
vascular e qual é a solução então
pessoal vitamina C portanto se você
alguém da sua família está passando por
isso eu aconselho a investir em
alimentos ricos em vitamina C sinal
número 18 fraqueza muscular e fadiga
você tem sentido músculos fracos e
doloridos ou está constantemente cansado
ou cansada isso pode ser um indicativo
de deficiência de selênio pessoal como
sempre falo é fundamental que você
procure um médico médica se estiver
enfrentando esse ou qualquer outro
sintoma persistente que Eu mencionei
nesse vídeo Muito obrigado pela sua
atenção um grande abraço e um beijo no
seu coração